- Now y'all have met before, right?
You've met, right?
- We met.
- We met when I was pregnant
with one of my kids.
- Yeah.
- [Kate] I think four years ago.
Yeah, four years ago.
- [Jane] Four years ago.
You were very pregnant.
- [Kate] Very.
(chuckles)
- You always love the
part when they get out
I love them more.
So, Dr. Jane, when did the love
of animals like first overwhelm you,
like, overpower you to where you felt
like this had to be your life?
- Well, apparently when I popped out
of my mother's womb.
- There you go.
Coming back to it.
You just were, from a
child, just obsessed.
Just loved animals.
- Yeah. I mean, I was 18 months old
and mom came into my room
and I got this whole handful
of earthworms in my bed
and she said, "you were looking at them
so you wondered how do
they walk without legs?"
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- And so she just quietly said
"let's put them back in the
garden or they might die."
So, she supported me from the very start.
- That's a beautiful thing.
Because lots of people
would come in and go,
"what are you doing?"
- "Throw those dirty
things out. How dare you?"
Yeah.
- But they are very cool.
I'm with you on that.
What was the moment you knew
you had to dedicate your life
to working with chimpanzees?
- Well, first of all, it was Africa.
I read "Tarzan of the Apes"
and fell in love with him.
- Yeah.
- And I was very jealous,
he married the wrong Jane.
(laughing)
- He really did.
- Yeah, he really did.
So, that was when my
dream of Africa began.
I grow up, go to Africa,
live with wild animals
and write books about them.
And everybody loved except again, mom,
"If you really want to
do something like this,
you'll have to work really hard.
Take advantage of every opportunity.
And if you don't get up,
hopefully you find a way".
Which I've spread that around the world,
especially in disadvantaged
communities, you know?
And so many people have
said, "Jane, thank you.
You taught me because
you followed your dream.
I can follow mine."
So anyway, I got out there--
- Absolutely.
It's inspiring.
- Yes. I met Dr. Leakey.
I would've studied any
animal to be in nature
and he offered me the one most like us.
Like, I mean, it's like fate, isn't it?
It was meant to be.
And so chimpanzees, I was sent off
to be the first person
ever to study chimpanzees.
- That's incredible.
So, did you have anything
you wanted to ask Dr. Jane?
- No, I just I hope I can
be a mom like your mom was.
It's really inspiring because all
of the things that you said, it's true.
Like our instincts are to go,
"Oh, don't do that. It's messy."
But in reality, all of
those little things,
they really do form a person.
- So you discovered chimpanzees use tools,
which changed everything really.
So do you remember that moment?
- Oh yes, of course.
I was walking through a
little trail in the forest
and I saw the first chimpanzee
who'd begun to lose his
fear of me, David Greybeard,
and he was using grass
stems to fish for termites.
And it was really exciting.
- That's really--
- At that time,
it was thought that humans
and only humans used and made tools.
Now of course we know other animals do.
- Absolutely.
Of course, humans thought
we were the only ones.
- Yeah.
- Look, there's a lot
of great things about us
but there's some not so great.